en una era de escándalos guerras
culturales y fachadas perfectas muchos
tienen miedo de expresar sus opiniones
Así que reunimos a siete extraños
protegimos sus identidades y les hicimos
siete preguntas polémicas
que revelarán estos enmascarados
[Música]
si su respuesta es Sí
enciendan su luz
ves pornografía
[Música]
es accesible y como lo es y está
disponible allí para todos
la gente la USA yo lo hago creo que la
mayoría de los chicos dirían que al
menos alguna vez la han visto y también
creo que si la disfrutas de una forma
sana si te masturbas de forma sana creo
que para mí está bien hacerlo
si yo veo porno
o cielos durante mi adolescencia pasé
mucho tiempo obsesionado con la
pornografía hasta que llegó a ser una
adicción de hecho hasta hace muy poco
dejé de pagar por ver porno la veo pero
no me gusta hacerlo ahora los demás
pueden participar en la discusión
dije que no antes veía mucha pornografía
diría que era adicto a la pornografía mi
padre está en prisión Así que en
realidad no tenía a nadie que me hablara
de sexo así que la pornografía fue mi
educación sexual en mi experiencia
personal me hizo daño Porque después de
ver tanta pornografía saben creo que
todos hemos pasado por eso de ir por la
página 5 y no encontrar nada estás
buscando el vídeo correcto pero tus
receptores de dopamina Y eso están
dañados para entonces que un video que
antes te pareciera erótico ahora te da
igual vi tanta pornografía que siendo un
hombre heterosexual empecé a ver porno
trans porque era erótica y diferente de
todo lo que había visto antes necesitaba
algo nuevo por la pornografía no sé por
la pornografía no creo que sea solo
entretenimiento en realidad afecta tu
cerebro y la forma en la que entiendes
el amor Crees que la mayoría de los
adolescentes o los chicos saben sobre
los efectos de la pornografía para nada
alguna vez Has llorado delante de
alguien más
[Música]
Estoy totalmente de acuerdo con esto
creo que es más fácil abrirse con las
mujeres y es un poco vergonzoso pero
siendo honesto siento que ella se
entiende más las emociones porque
entienden mejor esto de llorar siento
que para ellas llorar es normal y lo ven
como una forma de expresarse es
interesante que te sientas más cómodo
llorado delante de mujeres Tenía una
novia y terminó conmigo por mensajes
antes de eso estábamos hablando y lloré
delante de ella estaba haciendo honesto
Y pensé que era algo normal en esa
situación Pero supongo que ella lo
interpretó como que yo era inseguro y
luego terminó conmigo Eso me afectó
bastante por un tiempo porque sentía que
ya no podía volver a mostrar mi seguro
de ningún modo así que prefiero llorar
en frente de algún familiar de confianza
es interesante porque yo preferiría
hablar con un desconocido en la calle y
contarle todo lo que me está pasando
porque no volveré a verlo de nuevo
después y esa persona no podría juzgarme
no volvería a verlo otra vez pre que un
extraño piense que soy fuerte el que mi
familia sepa mis problemas el feminismo
ha llegado demasiado lejos
[Música]
el movimiento feminista siempre intenta
enfrentarse y pelear con los hombres o
ponerlos en su lugar
pero si las mujeres quieren que seamos
mejores creo que sería más productivo
que en lugar de enfrentarse a nosotros y
decirnos todo lo que hacemos mal nos
señalaran las cosas positivas eso nos
ayudaría a hacernos responsables en
nuestras acciones porque tenemos que
mejorar siento que es un poco Injusto
darle más oportunidades a las mujeres
para algunas cosas creo que hay que
trabajar por las cosas Hay que
esforzarse para ganárselas no creo que
las mujeres tengan menos acceso a
ciertos empleos sé que hay muchas
mujeres empresarias con negocios que
hacen cosas buenas por el país solo me
parece contradictorio que el movimiento
feminista luche por la igualdad de
derechos y ciertas cosas cuando ya
tienen acceso a ellas
soy feminista Supongo que creo en la
igualdad entre hombres y mujeres creo
que cuando hablamos de feminismo una
gran parte se reduce al empleo creo que
esto de desprestigiar a los hombres y
avergonzarlos como ustedes dicen que
hace el movimiento feminista es muy
exagerado nunca me han avergonzado por
mi masculinidad creo que si vemos
cualquier movimiento siempre va a haber
como una parte más radical de ese
movimiento por al mismo tiempo quiero
hacerles la pregunta a todos ustedes
alguno tiene una experiencia personal en
la que se ha sentido disminuido para
enaltecer a una mujer
un poco solo un poco en la secundaria no
fue lo peor del mundo en segundo año los
estudiantes hacíamos una actividad de
pensamientos felices todos los viernes
escribíamos algo y lo poníamos en una
caja muchas chicas y otros chicos
femeninos se hacían cumplidos entre
ellos que no está mal pero cuando lo
hacían se decían mirate eres genial y
luego yo recibía este insultos hacer un
día de pensamientos felices a un día de
enaltecer a las mujeres siento que hay
un muro que deberíamos derribar para
enfocarnos en todos los seres humanos
mujeres hombres mexicanos todos todos
deberíamos ayudarnos
el tamaño de mi miembro me causa
inseguridad
[Música]
empecé a ver pornografía creo que
alrededor de los 11 o 12 años estaba en
una edad en la que era muy impresionable
Y vulnerable por supuesto que sentía
ciertas emociones cuando miraba mi
cuerpo sí creo que lo que más me afecta
es la idea de competir y compararme
pienso en cosas como sé que hay muchos
chicos que lo tienen más grande que yo y
ellas dicen que no importa pero Sigo
pensando en ello cuando me voy a dormir
por las noches
en la actualidad No me molesta realmente
el tamaño de mi pene porque cada vez me
siento más cómodo con mi cuerpo y mi
forma de ser creo que no es algo que me
importe mucho cuando estás con alguien
durante 10 años Comparado con una pareja
casual de una noche Así que en lo
personal no me incomoda todo lo que
dijiste cierto solo hay que tener
confianza en él uno mismo y saber lo que
buscan otras personas Pero es difícil
meterse a Netflix y ver Euforia y pensar
estos hombres adultos hacen el papel de
adolescentes piensas demonios yo no me
veo así y luego piensas en todas las
personas con las que has estado que tal
vez hayan visto la serie creo que en
realidad por eso sientes ansiedad porque
es probable que los demás tengan sus
expectativas he cuestionado mi
sexualidad
[Música]
Bueno cuando estaba en la escuela nunca
fui uno de esos chicos deportistas
siempre me gustó la música me gustaba el
teatro Así que mientras crecía siempre
me molestaron por eso porque parecía muy
gay y siempre me juntaba con chicas
empecé a creer lo que todos decían y
sentía la presión social cuando decían
Oye eres gay al final vas a terminar así
porque eres así Ahora en este momento de
mi vida siento más confianza y sé cuál
es mi identidad cuando la gente piensa
eso comienzas a
cuestionarte a ti mismo te pones a
pensar demonios entonces soy gay debería
hacerlo y piensas deberían atraérmelos
chicos solo porque me gustan cosas que
se consideran gays Pero eso solo
demuestra otro problema y es que
nosotros decidimos que unas cosas son y
otras heterosexuales lo mío no fue por
Ninguna actividad extracurricular mi
duda fue por la porno como les dije
antes cuando empecé a ver pornografía
trans Es raro admitirlo pero me sentía
muy nervioso estaba nervioso porque
pensé que podía ser gay entonces
investigué un poco y me obsesioné
intentando descifrar lo que podía
significar en todas las cosas que
encontraba siempre decían Si ves porno
trans eres heterosexual porque son
mujeres y cosas así pero pensaba qué
pensaría mi familia nunca fui más allá
cada vez que hablaba con una mujer
retonante en la vida real no sentía
ninguna atracción Así que sigo un poco
confundido sobre lo que me atrae pero
creo que sigo siendo heterosexual porque
son mujeres
ahora me siento contento con mi
sexualidad y creo que no está mal
cuestionar Tu sexualidad aquí en Estados
Unidos eres libre de cuestionar lo que
quieras puedes cuestionar tu religión
puedes cuestionar tu cultura lo que te
limites la sociedad queriendo dictar lo
que es normal y lo que está mal
siento que hay un estigma muy fuerte
sobre la sexualidad es la sociedad que
te obliga a hacer heterosexual incluso
aquí siento la necesidad de explicarles
aunque hable de forma anónima por
ejemplo en mi caso solo he tenido
relaciones con mujeres cis pero sé que
nadie me está juzgando y todos estamos
aquí para ser honestos es un estigma que
es sentido los últimos 18 años de mi
vida en este momento me siento
avergonzado y apenado por algo que no
puedo controlar
tengo miedo de morir
[Música]
cuando pienso en ello de verdad me
aterroriza la idea de morir es que vi a
mi padre morir justo delante de mí y da
miedo solo dejó de respirar creo que la
idea de que no haya nada más después me
aterroriza por completo no tienes idea
de lo que pasa podría pensar seguiría
allí solo somos un parpadeo en el
espacio
es algo aterrador no sabemos nada como
cristiano quiero fingir que creo en el
cielo y en el infierno Pero al final del
día no sé nada
Sí creo que cuando era niño e iba
creciendo yo siempre tuve miedo de morir
y no lograr las cosas que quería hacer
en el mundo pero cada vez que pensaba en
morir imaginaba que estaría viejo hace
dos años cuando comencé a trabajar como
salvavidas una mujer y su amiga fueron a
la piscina yo estaba escuchando música y
la mujer comenzó a convulsionar por
suerte hice lo que debía y luego
llegaron los paramédicos y se recuperó
pero dos semanas después por desgracia
tuvo otra convulsión mientras conducía y
falleció y
entonces me di cuenta de que la muerte
puede alcanzar a cualquiera en cualquier
momento si solo muero y no hago nada con
mi vida eso da mucho miedo
dije que no tengo miedo a morir porque a
diferencia de ustedes en realidad no he
tenido experiencias cercanas a la muerte
tengo miedo del hecho de que moriré
algún día no
pero creo que obviamente pensar en que
es algo que podría pasar antes de lo
esperado me da un poco de miedo pero
creo que eso es lo que hace que la vida
sea especial me entienden creo que la
muerte es justamente lo que le da
sentido a la vida porque si no morimos
entonces nunca haríamos nada siempre
tendríamos más tiempo para todo
[Música]
sienten que realmente pueden ser ustedes
mismos cuando hablan con una chica o
cuando salen con ella para mí hay una
gran diferencia entre hablar o abrirme
con mis amigas mujeres que hacerlo con
una chica que me interese es obvio que
cuando quieres impresionar a una chica
tienes que vestirte bien usar perfume no
puedes soltar gases cerca de ella eso es
lo usual pero cuando se trata de tu
madre también es mujer Yo confío en mi
madre y me siento más cómodo siendo yo
mismo con personas de confianza creo que
se trata de eso muchas veces he hablado
con alguna chica que me interesa Y luego
pienso ni siquiera le mostré como soy en
realidad pero veo que mi mejor amigo o
el que solía ser mi mejor amigo es un
poco mujeriego tiene mucho éxito Con las
mujeres y cuando yo he tenido suerte con
una chica ha sido por seguir su ejemplo
y decirle lo que quieren Escuchar creo
que es bueno ser uno mismo porque no
puedes Fingir ser alguien más por
siempre
es reconfortante hablar con otros y
darme cuenta de que no soy el único que
siente estas cosas es agradable y es un
paso en la dirección correcta para
sentirme más cómodo siendo más abierto y
honesto con todo el mundo siento que
Toda esta conversación abierta es algo
positivo al final no pienso que alguien
vaya a escuchar esto y piense o ese
chico Es malo siento más seguridad dando
mi opinión más sincera Y aunque sean
buenas o malas opiniones es una mejor
forma de expresar lo que realmente
sientes sin sentirte influenciado por la
secundaria y las personas populares
porque la secundaria solo es cultura
popular lo que la gente considera
popular Muchas gracias
[Música]